Candy Truth. I was sitting on the couch
last night. Missy and I and two of her
grandkids. She had some kind of movie
on. I wasn't paying attention. And uh
she got up to walk out and as soon as
she did, Maris, the three-year-old, hey
Maris,
she just turned around like we were in
mid-con conversation
and said, "So, is Phil in heaven?"
And I said, "Yep." And the 2-year-old
went, "Yep."
So Maris said, "So we're happy."
I said, "Yep."
David said, "Yep."
You know, this is a very common
understanding, belief. What happens when
you die? This belief is that when people
die, they go to a better place. And you
need to be happy for them because
they're living a better life than us.
They're up there on streets of gold
praising the Lord. They're like seeing
all their dead loved ones that are now
they're reunited. It's like this happy
ending, right? And one day we'll be
reunited with them and we'll get to
spend eternity with them. That does
sound nice. But I want to know the
truth. The truth is more important than
what we've been taught our whole life or
what tradition says or just kind of
Yeah. It's our cultural belief, whatever
that is. So, let's go to the Bible
alone. And I'm going to break this down
because I'm a visual person. I'm a
visual learner. And if you guys are too,
this is going to be very helpful to you
because I like to use illustrations. I
like to use verses line upon line
because look, we cannot create doctrines
out of one verse. That's what I see
happen all the time. I can be like,
"This verse, this verse, this verse,
this verse, Old Testament, New
Testament, this verse, this verse." And
the person says, "Nope, this verse." And
I'm like, "Well, what about the 20 that
I gave you? It doesn't matter. This
verse." And I'm like, "How can you base
your whole belief system on one verse
probably out of context?" Because the
Bible doesn't ever contradict itself. Do
we believe that the Bible never
contradicts itself? Even if it two
verses seem to contradict, then we need
to go to the Greek, the Hebrew, read the
context, something is wrong. And if you
see one verse that seems to contradict
20, then you can bet that it's that one
verse that there's an issue. So go to
that verse, read the context, read the
whole chapter if you have to look at the
Greek, look at the Hebrew. What do these
words mean? Is there some kind of
translational missing in translation
going on? because that does happen.
We're reading the English translation of
Greek, Aramaic, and Hebrew. So, there's
bound to be we did we also did a show on
uh wine, alcohol. When the Bible says
wine, there's only one word for juice
and alcohol in the Greek and the Hebrew.
So, when it's translated to English, we
got this word wine, which in our current
modernday English, wine means al
alcohol. alcoholic beverage. But even in
our language, even in English a long
time ago, wine didn't mean that. It
meant juice or alcohol. So Welch's grape
juice when it first came out, it was
called non-alcoholic wine. They called
it wine because it was all that to say,
there are some translational
misunderstandings when you translate
other languages into English. So, going
back to the Greek and Hebrew using a
concordance, anybody can do it. You
don't have to be some scholar. And I'm
going to show you those things. So,
let's go to the board here. The
mainstream belief about what happens to
the righteous when they die is this is
your timeline of life. You got from the
beginning at birth to your life. You're
a walking adult. You're living, living,
living, and then one day you're going to
die. That's obvious. Everyone knows
this. Anyone in the physical world with
eyes and a brain knows that you're born,
you live, you die. What happens after
that is a mystery to the whole world.
And you have to pick what truth you
believe. I believe the Bible is truth.
It's proven itself over and over and
over again. Prophecy is coming true.
There's no way I cannot believe the
Bible. And what the Bible says, or
sorry, what popular belief says is that
when you die, your spirit, it's like a
ghostly version of you, exits your body.
It goes up to the kingdom of heaven
and then happily ever after, right? No.
Because
Jesus comes back. And when Jesus comes
back to earth
to rapture the saints,
then it says that the dead in Christ
will rise and they'll be, you know, put
on immortality and all that. So your
spirit, your ghostly spirit that's not
really a physical being comes down to
earth back to the grave and immediately
rises back up in an immortal body to
meet the Lord in the air. So this is
you're dead. You go up. You're there for
a thousand years or 2,000 or however
long it was when you died. You know, if
Adam, if that happened to Adam, he's
been up there for 6,000 years. He's been
up there. But when Jesus, as a spirit
being, Adam, this is the this is the
mainstream belief that when Adam died
6,000 years ago, he's been living as a
ghost in heaven, waiting for that body.
I And I'm not making this stuff up. I'm
not trying to make it sound worse than
it is. I've heard pastors on the radio
say that when you're a spirit, you you
don't have your physical body yet. So,
it's not as enjoyable. You're you're
still waiting and longing to get that
immortal body, that perfect body. So,
everyone in heaven right now lives as
spirit beings who are waiting to get
their physical body. I'm not making this
up. This is what mainstream belief
teaches. Whether they get into those
details or not is debatable. But this is
what when it when you break it down and
you say, "Wait a minute. I thought you
got to come down or I thought you um
when Jesus comes back, you're going to
rise up in a new body. Why would you be
in heaven?" And they say, "No, your
spirit is in heaven. Your spirit comes
back down when Jesus comes, but then you
got to go right back up to meet him
because that's why Jesus is coming to
resurrect the dead in Christ and give
them immortal bodies." So, you go right
back up to meet the Lord in the air. You
spend that seven years because this is
another popular belief that is not true
is a pre-tribulation rapture. So, they
believe you're in heaven for seven years
of hell and tribulation on earth and
then you come back down to the new earth
and you live on earth for eternity
uh for a perfect world for a thousand
years. then Satan's loosed. Deceives a
number like the sand of the sea. Good
luck being one of those that isn't
deceived. And if you are, then you get
to live in a perfect world forever. Now,
that's the mainstream belief. I was
raised in it. I know. I've watched a lot
a lot a lot of debates. A I've listened
to a lot of preachers. This is what they
teach. This is what they believe. I'm
not making it up. Now, what the
mainstream believe about the wicked,
what happens when the wicked die? Well,
here's your timeline again of life.
You're born, you live life, you die.
Then what happens to the wicked is their
spirit goes down into the flames of
everlasting hell. They're tormented,
tormented, tormented day in day out, no
break, hell, hell, hell, fire, torment,
torture. But then Jesus comes back and
what happens is there's a thousand years
Because remember, only the righteous are
caught up to meet the Lord in the air.
The wicked are still down there burning,
burning, burning. This is the mainstream
belief, not what I'm not what I believe.
I'll just go ahead and say this is not
what I believe. I don't believe this is
what the Bible teaches, but this is what
the majority of churches teach that the
wicked spirits are burning, burning,
burning. Second coming happens. They
stay there because only the righteous
living and the righteous dead are caught
up to meet the Lord in the air. Then
there's thousand-year reign on earth is
what they believe and the wicked are
still down there. And then the Bible
says the rest of the dead live not again
until the thousand years is finished. So
after this thousand years,
the the judgment comes. The wicked are
raised. Their spirits come out of hell
only to go right back into the lake of
fire with an immortal body to spend
eternity. So the only way that you can
actually burn for eternity is if you
have immortality.
So when this spirit comes up, obviously
at the judgment, God gives them an
immortal body so that they can burn,
burn, burn for eternity in the
neverending fires of hell. Now that's
mainstream belief, not what I believe
the Bible teaches, but this is it. So
just so you guys know, now this is what
I believe the Bible teaches. This is the
biblical truth about what happens to the
righteous. Here's your timeline. You're
born. You live life. You die.
Then you sleep in Christ. There's tons
of verses that say that the dead are
dead. They're sleeping. They're waiting
for the judgment. They're sleeping in
the dust of the earth. all these verses
that we're going to go into. But this
makes a lot more sense because the dead
who have died ever since Adam
and all those that are after it, those
righteous people who have died all
through history are still dead.
Then Jesus comes back at the second
coming
and they're given immortal bodies.
They've been dead. It feels like an
instant because they've been asleep.
What happens when you sleep? You fall
asleep, you wake up, boom, it feels like
no time at all. I'm here. Or if you go
under anesthesia or anything like that,
it feels like a moment. So these people
that have been dead for 6,000 years, to
them it feels like, oh, I took my last
breath and wow, I'm getting my immortal
body. And who are all these people? I'm
seeing millions of people being caught
up to meet the Lord in the air. When did
all this happen? Well, it's been 7,000
years, bro. like you've been asleep for
7,000 years. You've been dead. But now
we all got immortal bodies and we're all
going to see the King of Kings. Isn't
this exciting? We all get to go see him
at the same time. We're not trickling in
over the years. Like, oh man, I I've
been waiting for you up here. You're
finally up here, bro. Like, yeah. No,
it's a big party. We're all going to see
Jesus at the same exact time because it
says the dead in Christ shall rise
first. Now, how are how are there any
dead in Christ if the dead are really
alive in heaven? There'd be no such
thing as a quote unquote dead in Christ.
So, the second coming, you get your
immortal body, meet the Lord in the air,
you spend a thousand years, not just
seven, a thousand years in heaven
because it says that Satan's going to be
bound to uh to a desolate place, an
abyss. They call it the
um what is it called? The bottomless
pit. That's a bad translation because
when you look at the the Greek, it's
actually abusos, which is a parallel to
the word in Genesis that says that in
the beginning, God created the earth and
it was without form and void. Void means
abyss. So when Jesus comes, it says that
the dead in Christ will rise first.
Those who are alive and remain will be
caught up together to meet the Lord in
the air. So the righteous are removed
from the earth. And then it says the
wicked will be consumed by the
brightness of his coming. So who's left
on earth? No one. And if you read
Jeremiah 4:23 and the verses surrounding
it, it describes this time when earth
has no one left. The cities are broken
down. There's no man. The birds have
fled. It's a desolate void earth. That's
where Satan is going to spend a thousand
years death row sentence looking at all
the things that he's caused. Men's
skeletons as far as you can see. It
actually says that the birds are going
to be eating the flesh of the men that
have have been left behind, the wicked.
And Satan's here for a thousand years
thinking, I got my clock is ticking. In
a thousand years, God's going to come
and destroy me. That's where Satan is at
for a thousand years. So, a thousand
years, we're in heaven and then we come
back with Christ because it says Christ
and all his saints come to earth to
judge. Paul said, "Do you not know that
you will judge angels?" We're coming
back to judge with Christ. Because for a
thousand years, we've been going through
the books and we're like, "Why is
grandma not here? Oh, she had all these
secret sins I didn't know about. Oh, she
rejected Christ. Or why is he Yeah. Why
is he up here with us? This guy was a
murderer. Oh, well, he gave his heart to
me and he repented. You know, we're
going to get to go through the books and
see every secret sin, every decision
that was ever made. The rest of the dead
live not again until the thousand years
are finished. They're resurrected. The
wicked are raised to life to be judged.
And we get to be part of the jury. And
we get to say, "God, I know that that's
my grandma. I know that that's my
pastor. But I've seen how they rejected
you. I've seen how they've committed all
these sins and they never repented of
it. You are true and just and righteous
to destroy them." And if we ever had a
doubt, it says that Satan is going to
deceive them into battling against
Christ and trying to take over. They
compass the city of the saints and try
to take over the New Jerusalem by force.
And in that moment, we see their true
colors and fire comes down from God out
of heaven and devours them because
Christ has no choice. He has to protect
the ones he loves. He has to protect his
children from the wicked who are trying
to overtake the city. Now look at this
timeline.
Birth, life, death, sleep, resurrect in
an immortal body, spend a thousand years
in heaven, come back to earth. It's way
more simpler, way more logical, and
we're going to see that it's way more
scriptural as we go. Biblical truth
about the wicked. What happens to the
wicked when they die according to the
Bible? Here's your timeline. You're
born. You live life. You die.
At the second coming, because when
you're dead, you stay asleep. At the
second coming, you're still dead. You're
dead in sins. You don't get to
resurrect. Only the righteous resurrect
at the second coming. Then a thousand
years goes by
and then the judgment comes. And at the
judgment after the thousand years, it
says when the the rest of the dead live
not again until the thousand years is
finished, they're resurrected to their
judgment and they perish in the second
death in the lake of fire. That's what
the Bible says. We're gonna talk about
it. It's way different than what
mainstream belief teaches and we're
going to go through it. This has nothing
to do with denominations. This has
nothing to do with tradition. This has
everything to do what the scriptures
say, line upon line, and that's it.
Bible and Bible alone. Let's check out
these scriptures.
Psalms 146:4 says, "His breath goes
forth. He returns to his earth. In that
day his thoughts perish. So this verse
is saying that when you die, you're
dead. Your thoughts perish. You're not
going on to think somewhere in in in
paradise or in Hades or in heaven or
hell. Your thoughts perish in that very
day. And notice what it says. These are
important things. His breath, our
breath, that's what keeps us alive.
That's the miracle. That's the energy
life force that makes all humans alive.
I don't know where it comes from. I can
breathe air in somehow.
I breathe it out and I'm alive. But I
don't know when my last breath's going
to be. I don't know when my next if I'm
going to have a next breath. None of us
know. We could be 79 years old like Phil
and with no explanation your last
breath. Your breath is so important
because it's literally the breath of
God. It's the spirit of God keeping you
alive. He holds our very breath in his
hands. Keep that in mind. So we return
to the earth. Our breath goes forth.
Where does it go to? Where's our breath
go to? And we go to the earth. And in
that in that very day, our thoughts
perish. There's no more consciousness.
Body goes to earth. Consciousness cut
off. Breath goes forth. We're going to
find out where too. Genesis 2:7. This is
like the the recipe to human life.
And the Lord God formed man out of the
dust of the ground. So, we're literally
dust. Our bodies were made out of dust
and breathed. This is Adam breathed into
his nostrils the breath of life. It
doesn't say gave Adam a spirit ghost man
so that he could be alive. No, it says
breathed in his nostrils the breath of
life and man became a living soul. It
doesn't say God made man of the dust of
the ground and he gave him an immortal
soul that lives in him until death and
then departs at at death and will go on
living somewhere. That's the popular
belief that we I've heard it so many
times. Ray Comfort, all these guys, they
say you have an immortal soul and one
day when you die, you're gonna go
somewhere forever. Is it going to be
heaven or is it going to be hell? That's
not exactly what the Bible says. And
we're going to find out. So, man is made
of the dust of the ground. He has the
breath of life, which is the spirit of
God in his nostrils, your breathing. And
man became a living soul. There's no the
word soul does not mean a spirit ghost
man that lives inside your body and is
immortal. It means a living being. A
dead corpse is not a soul.
A dead dog, a dead human, not a soul.
Doesn't have a soul. It's not a soul
unless it's alive. Any, we're going to
prove this through the Bible. Any living
body is a soul. Any body with breath in
it. Your dog, your cat, fish, whatever.
even fish, which is odd because they
don't breathe. But any physical body
that is alive and breathing is a soul.
That's the definition. So when you hear
this word soul, no, you have an immortal
soul. Get that idea out of your mind.
That's not what the Bible teaches. This
is what we're going to find out. Then in
Genesis 2:7, it says what we just read.
So you look at this equation. This is
the recipe of life. Man is body, which
is dust. body and dust are the same
ingredient
plus spirit or breath because those
words are interchangeable. We're going
to look in the concordance and find out
that in the Hebrew and the Greek the
word spirit it's just the word breath.
That's all it is. Now there's different
context where it might be like uh you
know I'm in a happy spirit or something
like that but spirit always means breath
or wind or ruach or numa in the Greek
it's numa and which you think of
pneumonia is about breathing right
it means it's the Hebrew that's why you
got to put that in there
ruach is breath spirit is breath And you
put those two ingredients together, what
do you get? A living being. But what is
that living being called biblically?
That living being is called a soul.
Think of a pile of wood. Is that wood a
box? No, it's not. You got a pile of
wood and a pile of nails. Is it a box?
No. You have two ingredients. They are
nothing but wood and nails
until you put them together. You put the
nails in the wood. Now you have a box.
So you you don't have a box unless
they're together. If they're not
together,
it's not a box, right? That's common
logic. It's not a box. It's a pile of
wood and it's a pile of nails. If you
were trying to teach somebody English,
you would never point to a pile of wood
and nails and say that's a box. That
would be false. It's only a box when
it's built.
So Ecclesiastes
12:7 says,
"Then shall the dust, which is our body,
return to the earth,
as it was." So now we're now we're doing
it in reverse because God made us in the
opposite way. But now when you die, it's
it's the opposite. Your dust, your body
returns to the earth as it was. And the
spirit shall return to God who gave it.
Now remember what we saw spirit was
breath the breath of life. What did God
do? He breathed the breath of life into
god into Adam's nostrils. And the verse
we read back here says his breath goeth
forth. That word you could change it to
his spirit goeth forth. This in the
English it means the same thing. Breath
spirit it's the same. Numa, Ruach. In
Psalms, it would be Ruach. His Ruach
goeth forth and returns to where? Well,
we just found out it returns to God who
gave it because he's the lifegiver. He
He gives you the very breath you have
when you die. It's your breath that goes
to God, not some conscious ghostly
entity. And if that were the case, this
verse would be false because we know the
wicked aren't going to God, right? It
doesn't specify that when the righteous
die, your body goes to the dust and your
ghostly immortal spirit goes to God who
gave it. It doesn't say that. This is
talking about all life. And that would
be false. Whether it's animals or the
wicked, they're not their spirit is not
going to go to God. If you have the idea
and understanding that your spirit is
some immortal conscious ghost of
yourself, that's not true. This verse
proves it. The spirit, which is God's
breath, returns to God who gave it. So,
you're literally nothing at that point.
Your body returns to the dust. It rots
away, becomes bones,
and your spirit or breath goes back to
God. But there's no consciousness. there
is no longer a living being or a soul.
Now, to prove that from all these other
translations, I did a video about King
James being the best translation, but
there are times that it doesn't use a
word that makes the most sense. Like I
said, bottomless pit. That's a terrible
translation in the English. It should
have said that Satan will be cast into
the abyss or into a desolate void earth.
Those words would have been way more
accurate than a bottomless pit. So in
the contemporary English, the God's word
translation, good news translation, New
American Bible, New Revised Standard,
they all in this verse, it says the
lifegiving breath returns to God and the
breath returns to God. So over and over
we see that. Let's look at it in the uh
lexicon, the Strongs concordance. It
says right here the breath wind or
spirit is what that word means. So dry
earth dust turn back return earth land
breath wind spirit. That word that we
see is breath spirit or ruach as you can
see right here in this Hebrew word. So
it's not an immortal conscious ghost.
It's just the breath of God that gives
us life. That's why we're alive. That's
why we are a soul because we have that
life in us. Once we take that last
breath,
you breathe that out, you're no longer a
soul. You're dead.
So James 2:26 says, "For as the body
without the spirit or breath is dead, so
faith without works is dead also."
Now, this verse doesn't say, "Well, when
you die, you're actually still conscious
and alive somewhere." It says, "The body
without the spirit or breath is dead."
That's so clear. So, now we're going to
get the reverse of of creation. Death is
a reverse of creation. James 2:26 says,
"For as the body without the spirit is
dead." So look the first circle says
living being which is a soul which is a
living breathing person minus the spirit
or the breath equals dust. You're just a
corpse. You're a body but you're not
alive. You're a body which will turn
back to the dust. an unconscious
dead rotting corpse that no longer has
the spirit of life in you because that
spirit of life went back to the father
who gave it and you're no longer a
living being or a soul. So this idea
that hey you have a an an eternal soul
in you where is it going to go? That
terminology is completely false. That
definition is false. every living being.
The Bible even says that there was eight
eight souls on the ship. It wasn't a
ghost ship. It wasn't ship a ship with
spirits on it. Living beings are called
souls. So, let's reverse this with the
box analogy. You have a box minus the
nails. You take the nails out, boom,
what do you got? A pile of wood. It's no
longer a box.
It's it's just like you can have a
Kool-Aid pack and some sugar on the
table and a picture of water, but you
don't actually have Kool-Aid or a drink
until you mix it all together. It's just
ingredients out there. You have to mix
it together or else it's not a soul.
Breath plus dust equals living being or
soul. So Job 27:3 says, "All the while
my breath is in me or spirit or ruach is
in me and the spirit of God is in my
nostrils." Is Job saying that God's
ghost is in his nostrils? That some
little ghost man is hanging out in his
nose? No. So this right here says, "All
the while my breath is in me, which is
interchangeable with the spirit of God
is in my nostrils." It's not referring
to some conscious ghost or else this
verse would be comical, but it's not
what it means.
And Job chapter 14 is so clear. This is
like really it's nail in the coffin, but
I want to give all the evidence. But man
dieth and wasteth away. Yay, man give up
the ghost, which again is ruach. And
where is he? Job's asking God, where is
he? When he's dead, where is he?
As the waters fail from the sea, and the
flood decayth and dryth up, the same
exact way that the waters dry up, so man
lies down and riseth not.
He's not rising to the heavens. He's not
rising back to life. He's dead. Man lies
down and riseth not till when? Till the
heavens be no more. That happens when
Jesus returns. It says that when he
comes, the elements will melt with
fervent heat and the uh the heavens and
the earth shall pass away with a great
noise. Dude, the Bible is so
interconnected, perfect, airtight,
watertight knit that even Job, the
oldest book in the Bible. I know Genesis
is the first book of the Bible, but Job
is the oldest written book in the Bible,
works perfectly with the rest of the
Bible when it talks about Christ
returning and the heavens shall pass
with a great noise. Look, it says, "Till
the heavens be no more." How did Job
know that? Because God was giving him
this. Till the heavens be no more. So
you're not rising. Till the heavens be
no more. They shall not what? Awake nor
be raised out of their what? Sleep.
The Bible calls death asleep. And you're
not going to wake up. You're not going
to resurrect until the second coming
when the heavens will pass away with a
great noise. Oh that thou wouldest hide
me in my grave. I'm staying in that
grave. I'm not going to heaven or hell.
That thou wouldest keep me secret until
when? Until thy wrath be passed. What
wrath is it talking about? The wrath of
the plagues.
Because you're going to find that out
later. There's seven trumpets in the
book of Revelation. And Christ comes
back at the last trumpet. So that means
Christ returns at the end of the
plagues, which is God's wrath. And Job
says the same thing. Keep me secret,
hidden in my grave until your wrath of
the plagues is over and passed. Then I'm
going to resurrect at the second coming.
That thou wouldest appoint me a set time
and remember me. You got to remember him
because it's been a long time since Job
died. But God has not forgotten. He
remembers. If man dies, shall he live
again? He's asking the question, will he
live again? It doesn't say, "Oh, when I
when I die, I'm going to be alive
still." Shall he live again? All the
days of my appointed time, I wait
I wait till my change comes. What is the
change he's talking about? It's in first
Corinthians, the New Testament. Job, the
oldest book in the Bible, is referring
to something that Paul later talks about
in the New Testament where he says,
"Behold, I show you a mystery. We shall
not all sleep.
He's not saying we don't sleep. He's
saying we're not all just going to stay
asleep because we shall all be changed
in a moment in twinkling of an eye when
at the last trumpet.
For the trumpet shall sound and the
dead, not those who are alive in heaven
coming back down to earth and those who
are in hell coming back up to earth. No,
the dead shall be raised out of the
grave that Job's talking about. Not
Look, if you're if you're dead, if
you're grandma died and you think she's
in heaven right now, why is it saying
the dead shall be raised? You can't be
raised if you're in heaven and you'll be
raised incorruptible and we shall all be
changed. So, Job said this. He said that
we're going to wait until my change
comes. He's quoting Paul before Paul
ever came onto existence.
Thi this stuff is nail in the coffin.
You can't dispute it. It's Bible line
upon line. And we're not even halfway
through. There's 50 slides at least.
1 Corinthians chapter 15. It goes on and
it says, "For this corruptible," you
know, many people say that that we're
all inherently immortal. that when you
die, you're gonna go on living somewhere
forever. Where's it going to be, buddy?
Heaven or hell? But that's not what it
says. It says this corruptible must put
on incorruption.
When do we do that? I I haven't ever put
it on. And this mortal I'm I know I'm
mortal. I must put on immortality. When
do I do that? When am I going to put on
immortality? Because I don't have it
now. So when this corruptible shall have
put on incorruption, and this mortal
shall have put on immortality, then
shall be brought to pass the saying that
is written, death is swallowed up in
victory. Oh death, where is thy sting?
Oh grave, where is thy victory? Look,
everybody that's died right now, death
has conquered. Death always has victory
in this fallen world. No one can escape
it. Death always gets the victory. But
when Christ returns, he's going to
change us in the moment of the twinkle
of an eye. He's going to give the
righteous immortality. We're going to
put it on and then we'll come to pass.
Oh death, where's thy sting? Where is it
at now? Oh grave, where is thy victory?
Christ has the victory and he's given me
the victory. But only then, right now,
we're still in a fallen world and the
dead are dead. Victory is in the grave.
Victory is in the death until Christ
returns.
Ecclesiastes chapter 9 says, "For the
living know that they shall die, but the
dead know not anything."
Wait a minute. I thought the dead were
up there praising the Lord. I thought
the wicked were down there suffering in
torment. I thought they knew something.
But the Bible says the dead know not
anything. You know, there's people out
there that'll say, "Oh, this is talking
about the dead body."
Uh, is the Bible now Captain Obvious?
like, "Oh, you see that corpse right
there? Yeah, it knows nothing." Well,
duh. I know a corpse isn't thinking. I
know a corpse doesn't know anything. The
Bible's not trying to tell us that
corpses don't think. It's saying that
when you're dead, you're not conscious
anywhere. Because there's a lot of
beliefs out there. Oh, I have many
lives. Reincarnation,
heaven, hell, all the Hades, paradise,
all these things. There's all these
beliefs out there about being immortal.
And the Bible says, "Nope, the dead know
nothing. You are dead. Neither have they
any more reward, for their memory of
them is forgotten. Also, their love,
their hatred, their envy is now
perished. Neither have they any more
portioned forever
in anything that is done under the sun."
So, in this lifetime, they're dead.
Notice it says their love. Wait a
minute. If they're really alive in
heaven, they would have to be
experiencing love. They would have to be
showing love. Heaven is whole is based
on love. God's kingdom is based on love.
And yet it says their love is perished.
Their hatred is perished. All these
sinful things is perished.
Psalm 115:17 says, "The dead praise not
the Lord, neither any that go down into
silence."
So some people might read this and say,
"Oh, the dead is actually talking about
the wicked. Those that are, you know,
dead to sins and tres dead in sin and
trespasses." But it clarifies and said,
"Neither any that go down into silence,"
meaning in the grave. So the dead are
not walking streets of gold praising the
Lord. The Bible says so right here. The
dead praise not the Lord.
Ezekiel 18:4. Sorry about getting fired
up, guys. The Bible excites me. The
truth excites me. I hate deception. I
hate lies. I hate false doctrine. The
truth will make you free. And I want to
open the eyes of the whole world to what
the Bible really says and stop believing
false doctrine and deception that's
coming literally out of the church. Ez,
and there's good reason. Why? Why does
the Bible say to stay far from
necromancy?
Why Why does God forbid necromancy?
Because you can't talk to the dead. And
yet, how many people are saying, "Mom, I
know you can hear me up there." Uh,
just look over me and give me a sign.
You know, there's people that talk to
the dead,
innocent,
good, good, uh, intentioned people,
Christians talking to the dead. Catholic
do it all the time. Catholics talk to
dead apostles.
Uh Mary, all these people are dead and
and the Bible forbids speaking to them.
Do not talk to the dead. It's
necromancy. It's an abomination and it's
a lie from the pit of hell because Satan
comes as a familiar spirit. Oh, my mom.
I'm real familiar with my mom and I I
see her at night. Did I talk to her at
night? That's not true.
My mom passed away. She's sleeping.
She's waiting the resurrection. And if
Satan tries to impersonate my mother and
visit me, don't you think that would be
hard not to fall for that deception? I
miss my mom so much. If I saw her again,
I would be filled with emotion,
excitement. She would tell me things
that only me and her knew, but also evil
watching spirits knew my mom's
personality, knew the things that she
said to me, and he can impersonate them
perfectly as familiar spirits.
And what if he appeared as my mom and
came to me and said, "Mikey, this stuff
you're believing is not true. Everyone
gets to go to heaven. Everyone.
God loves everyone just the way they
are. Even the most wicked people are in
heaven. I've heard that testimony. A
woman, an atheist woman died on the
table, on the operating table.
And she said she went to the the light.
She was floating to the light. She felt
overwhelming love and joy and all these
things. And she goes, "Oh, this is
great. Does everyone get to feel this?"
And the light said, "Yes." And she said,
"Even Hitler?" And the light said,
"Yes." And when she came back, she said,
"I'm no longer afraid of death because I
know what it's like on the other side
and it feels amazing and everyone gets
to go."
If you believe that, then you are highly
deceived. We cannot we cannot buy into
these neardeath experiences. Oh, I can't
believe what you're saying, Mikey,
because I heard 23 seconds or 23 minutes
in hell. I heard this story. Uh, heaven
is for real. I'm I'm not going to put
trust in men. I'm not going to put trust
in people who died on operating table
who were pumped full of pharmarmacia
drugs. I'm going to put my trust in the
Bible and the Bible alone. We have to or
we will be deceived in the last days. So
Ezekiel 18:4 says, "Behold, all souls
are mine. As the soul of the father, so
also the soul of the son, notice all
these words, soul, soul, soul, is mine.
The soul that sinnth, it shall what?
Die.
Wait a minute. I thought the soul goes
on living forever.
I die, but my soul goes on, right, to
heaven or hell. No, it's not what the
Bible says. The soul that sins, it shall
die. It doesn't just say it once.
Ezekiel 18:20 says, "The soul that sins,
it shall die." It says, "The soul," why
doesn't it say the body that sins, it
shall die? Because the soul is a living
being, not some immortal ghost that goes
on living somewhere. Revelation 16:3
even refers to sea life as a soul. It
says every living soul died in the sea.
This isn't talking about men swimming
around in the sea. It's talking about
fish. Even sea life are called souls and
they die.
Matthew 10:28 says Jesus his own words
and fear not them which can kill the
body. Okay, even a man can kill the
body, right? But are not able to kill
the soul.
Why? Because only God has the power to
annihilate, kill that soul, the living
being. Because when he comes back,
that's the judgment. Are you going to
receive eternal life or are you going to
see receive eternal death? He's the one
that makes the last judgment. Is this
soul going to live or die? Only he can
do it. But rather fear him which is able
to destroy
both soul and body and hell. Hell
meaning the grave. Hell meaning
destruction by fire. We're going to get
into all that. But it says the word
destroy. destroy does not say who is
able to torture for endless eternity the
soul and body in hell doesn't say that
who's able to destroy the soul
Christ says that John 3:16
the most famous verse in all of history
says for God so loved the world that he
gave his only begotten son that whoever
shall believeth in him or whosoever
believeth in him should not what perish
but have everlasting life. You know what
the majority of the Christian world is
teaching? You don't need Jesus to have
everlasting life. We all have
everlasting life. When you die, you're
going to get to experience it. You might
get to experience it in a bad place, but
you all have it. Isn't that the first
lie that was told to mankind?
When the serpent was in the garden, the
first lie ever spoken to a human was,
"You shall never die." You shall not
die. Are you kidding me? You won't die.
And that's what churches teach today.
Oh, you won't die. When you die, when
you die on this earth, you're going to
go on living conscious forever and ever
and ever and ever. Is it going to be
heaven or hell, buddy? But the Bible
says perish. These are your two options.
perish or everlasting life.
So the wages of sin is death,
but the gift of God is everlasting life.
So do the wicked get everlasting life,
or is it really a gift from God like the
Bible says? All right, let's see.
Hebrews 9:27 says, "There's so many
verses I didn't even include in here.
Like the one I just quoted, not even in
here, and there's still so many."
Hebrews 9:27 says, "And as it is
appointed unto men once to die, but
what? After this the judgment." It
doesn't say after this eternal bliss or
after this eternal torment.
After this the judgment. When does the
judgment come? When you read the Bible
and you hear about the great white
throne judgment, does that happen
immediately to everyone right after they
die? I'm dead. Judgment dead. Judgement.
No. No. No. There is a time when the
judgment happens and it's not
immediately after death. So what's it
say? It's appointed unto men once to
die. We're all going to die. But what's
my next conscious thought? The judgment.
When does the judgment come? Jesus said
unto her, this is talking about Lazarus.
Thy brother shall rise again. He's not
risen yet. He shall though. And Martha
said unto him, I know that he shall rise
again in the resurrection
at the last day. Wait, she knew that
Lazarus was dead, that he wasn't alive,
that he wasn't risen yet, but he was
going to rise one day. And the last day
when Jesus comes back, the last day,
that's when the judgment comes. Because
John 12:48 says, "He that rejecteth me
and receiveth not my words hath one that
judgeth him. The word that I have
spoken, the same shall judge him in the
last day." The judgment comes in the
last day. Not his last day, the last
day. When Christ returns, there's time
no more because we're living for
eternity, right? The righteous do. Time
ceases because the wicked are going to
be destroyed. So they don't have to keep
time anymore. And the righteous live
forever. So time ends when Christ
returns in the last day. At the last
trumpet.
Daniel 12:2 says, "And many of them that
sleep." Where are they sleeping? Not in
Abraham's bosom, not in Hades, but in
the dust of the earth. Not in shol. But
in the dust of the earth shall awake.
So, wait. They're asleep. They're not
like enjoying paradise or suffering in
flames.
I know there's going to be questions. I
know the comment section is going to be
full of questions. But remember,
how many verses are saying all this? And
what about that one or two verses? Oh,
doesn't it say the smoke of the torment
rises forever? Doesn't it say uh that
Lazarus or the rich man was in Hades and
he just wanted a drop of water on his
tongue? It was a parable. I know that's
going to be triggering, but look at any
Bible and and look at it where it says
the parables of Jesus Christ. Rich man
Lazarus is right there because he was
speaking a whole list of parables. And
he said, you know, a sewer was sewing
seed. Uh a a person was building their
house on the sand. It was all parables.
If you take it literal, you miss the
whole point. It's like, yeah, Jesus, I
don't know. He's some guy teaching me
how to grow crops and build a house. No,
you miss the whole spiritual lesson. The
spiritual lesson of the rich man and
Lazarus was that
the rich man thought he was going to get
to be in the kingdom of heaven because
of his bloodline and his wealth. They
taught back then that your wealth was a
sign of blessing from God. That you were
blessed and you're a Jew, man. You're
you're automatically a shoe in. But when
they died in this parable because what
did he say? Hades and and uh Abraham's
bosom.
When Jesus started speaking this
parable, he didn't have to clarify to
his audience, "By the way, this is a
parable." It'd be like me saying, "Um,
once upon a time, there was uh a girl
named Alice and she tumbled into
Wonderland and somebody raised their
hand, uh, is this real life?" No, it's
not. It's a fairy tale. It's a It's just
a story. his audience knew when they
heard him say uh there was Hades which
is Greek mythology
and there was Abraham's bosom which is
Jewish tradition. He was using both the
cultural views of the day. You were
either a pagan a Roman pagan or you were
a Pharisee or a Jew or you know the
traditional Jew. So there was just like
today we have pagans and Christians. I
mean, there's there's world views out
here. Jesus said, "One man died and he
went to Hades." This is just a story, by
the way, a parable. And one man died and
he went to Abraham's bosom. By the way,
why would Abraham be the one that is
like, you know, aren't we supposed to
meet Jesus, not Abraham? And how big is
his chest to have all these people in
it? And
what about when Adam died? Abraham
didn't even exist. So, what happened to
Adam when he died? Did he go to
Abraham's bosom? Well, Abraham wasn't
even born yet. So, this whole thing is
is a parable. I just had to get that out
of the way because it's going to come
up. We sleep in the dust. We wake up
some to everlasting life, some to
everlasting contempt.
Contempt means punishment.
Your punishment is death in the second
eternal death, everlasting death. We're
going to talk about that more. John
3:13.
This is Jesus talking though. And no man
has ascended up to heaven. None. Now,
some people get this idea that, well,
nobody went to heaven until Jesus died
on the cross. And now, everyone that
dies after the crucifixion of Jesus,
they go to heaven. And I don't know.
Give me this. Give me the chapter and
verse. That's all I need to know. One
one chapter and verse for that. I'll
believe it. Until then, I don't believe
that. Acts 2:9 says, "Men and brethren,
let me freely speak unto you of the
patriarch David." This is Paul in Acts
talking about David the psalmist who
fought Goliath, a good man, right? A
mana for God's own heart. That he is
both dead. He's dead, not alive in
heaven. Notice it says that and buried
and his suppler is with us to this day
or his gravestone or tomb. And then it
goes on, for David is not ascended into
the heavens. And people say, well,
because he was an Old Testament saint,
he didn't get to go to heaven. But all
the people after the cross, they get to
go to heaven. No, that's not the way it
works. That's not how God operates.
Like, well, if you died before my son
died, then you have to go somewhere
else. You have to stay in the grave or
you got to go to purgatory or Abraham's
bosom. But everybody that dies after the
resurrection of Jesus, they get to go to
heaven. So, tough luck. No, it says
David has not ascended into the heavens.
Um John 11 says this is about Lazarus
Jesus friend. These things said he and
after that he said unto them our friend
Lazarus what? Sleeps. He used the word
sleep. I know when you talk about this
subject when you try to share this
subject people go oh you believe in soul
sleep. Oo it's like calling somebody a
conspiracy theorist. It's like, oo,
you're a conspiracy theorist because you
question the government and question um
current events and all this stuff
because because you question the media
and the news, you're a conspiracy
theorist. If you believe what the Bible
says about death, you believe in soul
sleep. It's a it's a bad name. It's a
taboo label. But the Bible actually says
it. For one, a soul is a living being
and the dead are asleep because one day
we're going to awake. So death is like
asleep. It's not final unless you're the
wicked and you get thrown into the
second death. For the righteous, sleep
is death is but asleep. That's what it
says. Lazarus sleeps, but I go that I
may awake him out of sleep. And the
disciples said, "If he sleeps, he shall
do well. How be it?" Jay Jesus spoke of
his death. So Jesus said he's asleep,
but he's really saying he's dead. But
they sought that he had but they thought
he had spoken of taking rest in sleep.
Then Jesus said unto them plainly,
"Lazarus is dead." He's like, "Look,
he's dead. Sleep is death because
Lazarus was a righteous man and I'm
going to wake him up and he's going to
wake up uh when he dies again." I guess
I guess Lazarus had to die twice, but he
got resurrected. He will be resurrected
again.
1 Peter chapter 3 says, "For Christ also
hath once suffered for sins." This is
I'm going to get into the topic of hell
here because I know that's people are
thinking, "Okay, well, if you're asleep,
what happens? What about hell?"
Uh, so for Christ also hath once
suffered for sins, the just for the
unjust, that he might bring us to God,
being put to death in the flesh, but
quickened by the spirit.
What is this spirit? It's the spirit of
God. God's spirit quickened or awakened
Christ and raised him from the dead. Now
it says by which also he meaning God's
spirit
or Christ because Christ existed before
the New Testament before we saw we see
him born in the in Bethlehem in the
manger. Um Jesus existed in the Old
Testament, right? And it's saying his
spirit, Jesus spirit, the spirit of
Christ quickened him. He raised himself
to life. His same spirit
went and preached unto the spirits in
prison.
Now, this word spirits, when you look it
up, it's actually souls. It's living
beings. Now, people read this and they
say, "Look, when Jesus died, he went to
hell,
which is crazy because how would Jesus
go to hell at all? He was sinless. Yes,
he took on the sins of humanity,
but nobody really goes to hell because
they're all asleep when you know the
truth about the Bible." So, he didn't go
to hell, but when they see this, it
says, "Oh, he must have been preaching
to spirits in prisons of hell." But it
says that his spirit preached to people
in prison which sometimes were
disobedient when the longsuffering of
God waited when? In the days of Noah. So
this whole time frame that we're looking
at is in the days of Noah. That's the
whole context. In the days of Noah, the
spirit of Christ
through Noah preached to all the wicked
people. Noah had prison ministry. Noah
went to the people in prison and said,
"Hey man, you need to receive Christ.
You need or God, you need to accept God.
You need to believe the truth uh because
there's a big flood coming and you need
to get right with God."
And it says while the ark was preparing
wherein few that is, eight souls were
saved by water. So it's not saying that
Jesus went down to hell, preached to
spirits and he saved eight souls.
This is talking about being saved from
the water. Only eight. Noah, his wife,
and his sons and daughters and and
in-laws. Only eight were saved. But this
this whole context is that the spirit of
Christ in the Old Testament preached
through Noah. Because don't isn't that
what we do? When we go to preach like
Noah did, we say, "God, fill me with
your spirit. Not my words, but your
words. Give me your words, Lord. Hide me
behind your cross. I don't want none of
me. All of you. More of you, less of me.
That's what Noah did, too, right? So,
the spirit of Christ spoke through Noah
to the wicked people, but only eight
people are saved by water, from the
water.
Now, some people think, "Oh, when you
die, you actually go to paradise." And
then you go to heaven once Jesus comes
back and your spirit goes back down to
earth and you get your new body and you
go directly back up to heaven and your
new body and you're up there for seven
years and then you come back down to
earth and live forever. There is an idea
that they say, "Oh, that parable Jesus
taught about Abraham's bosom, that's
actually paradise." You can't prove that
with scripture. Give me the scripture
that says Abraham's bosom equals
paradise. It doesn't exist. Paradise
isn't another place. Paradise is heaven.
So there's no, you know, this is where
this is where the idea of purgatory came
from. That there's actually some other
kind of holding chamber until you get to
go to heaven or hell. That's purgatory.
That's the definition of purgatory is
another holding cell, a holding area
until you get to go to heaven or hell.
So paradise, what is paradise according
to the Bible? It's only three times in
the Bible ever the word paradise. 2
Corinthians 12:4 says, "How that he was
caught up into paradise." Paradise is
not down in the earth shol or Hades and
paradise. You know, there's a great gulf
dividing. You know, this is a popular
belief even in more uh nontraditional
circles that are around right now, Torah
keepers and things like that. They say
when you die, you go to Shil, which is
down below the earth, and you go to
paradise or Hades, and there's a great
gulf between them. But it says right
here how that he was caught up
up into paradise. Paradise is up there
somewhere. and heard unspeakable words
which are not lawful for man to utter.
He saw things that he can't even put
into words. Like there's no there isn't
words don't exist to explain what I saw.
Now line upon line we got to study
because Luke 23:43 says and Jesus said
unto him verily I say unto thee today
shalt thou be with me in paradise. So
when Jesus was on the cross he told that
thief on the cross you will be with me
in paradise. Where's paradise? Is it
where did Jesus go? Did Jesus go to some
holding chamber with the thief or did he
go to be with the father? That's what he
said when Mary came, right? He said,
"Touch me not. I have not yet ascended
to the father." And he went up and they
watched him go up into the sky. He went
up to paradise to be with his father.
Now, you might read this verse and say,
"Wait a minute. This debunks everything
you just said." Because Jesus said,
"Today you will be with me in paradise
today."
The only problem is this contradicts
everything I've just shown you. This one
verse contradicts 20 verses that I've
given you, 20 plus verses, and the Bible
never contradicts itself.
A a fun fact about the original Greek
and Hebrew is there's no punctuation in
the Bible. No punctuation in Greek and
Hebrew. So every comma, every period,
every punctuation was literally put
there by English-speaking men, English
translating men. And their understanding
was, "Oh, when you die, you go to
heaven." And right here, Jesus is
saying, "Today you're going to be with
me in heaven." But the way we should
really read this according to the Greek
that it was written in is Jesus said
unto him, I'm telling you today, I'm
mark my words today. I'm telling you,
write it on your calendar. You will be
with me in paradise. I promise you, you
will. Even though you were a sinner and
you're nailed to a cross right now and
you deserve it,
you will be with me in paradise. Will
be. That's a future context.
But that comma should be right here.
I'm telling you today,
you will be with me in paradise. Now,
Revelation 2:7
tells us exactly where paradise is. He
that hath an ear, let him hear what the
spirit has said unto the churches. To
him that overcome, I will give to eat of
the tree of life which is in the midst
of paradise of God. So where's the tree
of life today? Is it on earth? Is it
down somewhere in sh?
No, it's in the paradise of God. Is God
down there in sh?
Is his throne down there in Sheil or in
Hades or par, you know, Abraham's bosom?
No.
Paradise of God is in heaven. The case
closed. Three verses prove it. You're
caught up. I tell you today, you're
going to be with me up there. And that's
where Jesus is. He's not in shield. And
paradise is where the tree of life is
and the paradise of God. Actually, I can
show you a verse that actually breaks it
down even more. Um, where is the throne
of God right now? Where is the throne of
God? If you guys want to become a
Patreon to help support this channel, it
would mean the world to us. We can only
do this with your support. And I just
gave that plug because Patreon's right
there. But King James Bible,
um, what is it? God, uh, throne,
River of Life. Check this out.
So, check this out.
And he showed me a pure river of water
of life, clear as crystal, proceeding
out of the throne of God and of the
Lamb. So where's the throne of God?
It's not in Sheil. It's not in Hades.
It's not in Abraham's bosom. It's up
there where the river of life is and the
tree of life. The river of life and the
tree of life are in the same place. And
it's the same place where God's throne
is. God's throne is not in sh down below
the earth. It's up in paradise because
paradise is heaven. It's not some
holding chamber. We're only teaching the
truth here. We're going to talk about
the truth. We're going to get candid
with it. So, eternal hell. This is a
topic that uh this is going to trigger
some people for some reason. I the truth
set me free. I like the truth about
hell. Um and we're going to get into it.
So Acts 2:27 says, "Because thou wilt
not leave my soul in hell, neither wilt
thou suffer thine holy one to see
corruption." He's actually, this is in
Acts. This is Paul quoting David the
Psalmist when he said, "For thou wil not
leave my soul in hell, neither wilt thou
suffer me, holy one, to see corruption."
Why is David saying he's going to hell?
Good question, right? David was a
righteous man. Why is he saying, "I'm
going to be in hell, but you won't leave
my soul there." Right? Because